I'm just waiting for the right moment to  like become a housewife financially you  know I want my husband to get us to like  a certain point financially I want to  get to the point as a couple where I can  comfortably afford sliced mango I'm  talking about I'm talking about that  Whole Foods mango that 10 a box Whole  Foods mango that was sliced by white  people that's the kind of income bracket  I'm striving for that's when you know  you've made it when you're eating Mango  that was sliced by a dude named Noah I  want Noah mango  Rebecca kiwi Danielle pineapple I have  to admit that this joke in its  specificity is going over my head a  little bit and I you know I've been  inside a Whole Foods maybe twice in my  entire life I'm also not a big mango guy  so I'm not familiar with the mango  culture maybe if you're a big Whole  Foods fan and an avid mango Enthusiast  this material is Just Killer but the  game here is to make me laugh and I am  not laughing